le ministre de l'éducation nationale
vincent peillon est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir jean michel bouquet merci
d'être avec nous l'école conduit mal sa
mission le niveau régresse les
inégalités s'aggravent ce constat bien
sûr nous accable tous mais votre
ambition et votre action réformatrice ou
la façon dont vous l'amenez ne suscite
pas l'adhésion générale à vincent
peillon c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
avec katell prigent de l' agence
france-presse note notre partenaire avec
dailymotion et puis perrine tarneaud de
public sénat nous parlerons également de
l'état de l'exécutif le gouvernement
donc vous êtes le numéro 3 et puis
comment se porte le duo hollande héros
justement on ne vous a pas encore
entendu sur ce rapport sur l'intégration
mis en ligne d'autres jours enfin il ya
un mois maintenant sur le site de
matignon vous à l'origine de la charte
de la laïcité qui a été affiché dans
toutes les écoles vincent peillon j mais
j'imagine que vous êtes tombé de votre
siège ce matin là non parce que moi je
suis très attaché je connais bien les
débats en france à la liberté
d'expression de conscience que des
intellectuels émettent des avis des
jugements des propositions ne dérange
pas du tout
premier ministre non plus c'était
l'objet quand vous dites je fais deux
grandes délibérations je demande aux
gens de s'exprimer les gens peuvent
consulter maintenant ce qui importe
c'est quelle est la position du
gouvernement position du gouvernement
n'était évidemment pas du tout engagé
par des réflexions qui parle d'ailleurs
dans des sens très divers qui sont le
résultat
de ces différentes réflexions aux
différents travaux et donc ce qui m'a
aussi si vous voulez surpris et et
désagréablement région est riche et
toujours la même chose c'est la loi de
2004 seynois qui a été voté par la
gauche et par la droite il n'y a aucun
contentieux depuis je vous parle
communiste de l'éducation nationale
c'est une bonne loi elle ne pose pas de
problème
le président de la république le premier
ministre moi même un ensemble des
ministres sommes attachés à cette loi
est certain dans la théorie du soupçon
dans la volonté de créer de la polémique
mais quand même une très grande
déstabilisation de ce que nous avons en
commun dans le pays ferait comme si nous
serions engagée par le complot d'un
sociologue ou le propos alors qu'ils
connaissent nos positions ils savent que
nous avons voté cette loi et que nous la
défendrons mais que ce n'est pas une
bonne lutte et le premier ministre a dit
que c'était un excellent travail il a
salué ses rapports ils remettent en
cause que vous dites ce à quoi je le
sais vous êtes attachés il peut arriver
que l'on soit poli ce n'est pas interdit
en france et certains devraient sans
menez qui n'inspiraient y compris à
droite dans les réactions et les cris
d'orfraie de monsieur copé qui sait très
bien que il n'alimente pas là un vrai
débat mais qu'il joue sur des peurs et
qui lit dans du positionnement politique
on a besoin de sincérité quand vous avez
une centaine d'intellectuels d'experts
de sociologues qui acceptent des taux
réduits en charge je sais pas s'ils sont
de gauche droite mais enfin qui accepte
de produire des réflexions et qui
voulait remettre vous avez la politesse
de leur dire je vous remercie vous
faites tous les mêmes choses quand vous
êtes premier ministre de la france d'une
politique à conduire des décisions à
prendre vous n'êtes pas engagé par ses
réflexions ça n'empêche pas d'être poli
vous imaginez où on en est mais pourquoi
ces cris d'orfraie pourquoi cette
volonté de diviser à nouveau sur un
thème qui nous rassemble il ya des
arrière pensées il y a des gens que tu
as entendu à lui mais aussi faire monter
le front national mais je pense avec
beaucoup de sincérité que
l'attitude d'une partie de l'ump car
l'ump très divisé et je pense en
particulier à jean françois copé en
rajouter tout le temps le pain au
chocolat il m'a semblé c'était quand
même lui des propos à de multiples
moments des pétitions chaque fois et
maintenant cette réaction au lieu de
dire ce qu'ils étaient quelles sont vos
intentions de nos intentions c'est qu'on
revient pas sur la liste
je vais aller au bout de mon propos et
je pense que jean françois copé doit
faire attention parce qu'il fait la
campagne du front national je les ai
déjà dit quand vous regardez alors lui
parle du ps fm1 d'accord mais il faut
s'intéresser au fait ça n'est pas
interdit il ya eu brignoles à brignoles
nous appelons à voter pour la droite moi
j'ai voté jacques chirac et lorsqu on
fait l'analyse des bureaux de vote on se
rend compte que avec ce type d'attitude
et de porosité des électeurs de l'ump le
candidat de son nez plane d'ailleurs ont
voté front national alors que les
socialistes sont allés voter ump parce
que avant notre orientation politique
nous sommes dans le champ républicain et
nous croyons qu'il faut d'abord
préserver la république et je considère
il ya un malaise à droite je considère
que ce que fait jean françois copé comme
premier responsable de l'ump division
camp et n'est pas habile l'ump c'est un
grand parti républicain de droite
républicaine et il ya un certain nombre
d'attitudes qui gêne on le voit bien à
l'ump et en particulier ce genre
d'attitude qui consume a rappelé l
ajustement son attachement aux valeurs
républicaines à la laïcité c'est ce
qu'on a voulu faire de la laïcité comme
madame le pen un facteur de division des
français nous lorsque nous votons la loi
de 2004 nous mettons la laïcité au delà
le clivage gauche droite comme les
valeurs constitutionnelles c'est une
valeur constitutionnelle ce monsieur
copé ne semble pas l'avoir compris et il
veut en faire un objet de polémique et
de divisions entre les partis
républicains il a tort et il ne fait pas
du bien à la france en faisant sur la
loi sur le voile à l'école ne se discute
plus aujourd'hui vous l'avez rappelé
effectivement vincent peillon est ce
qu'il ya quand même des élèves qui se
trouvent exclus du système scolaire en
raison de son implication est
extrêmement rare sait combien les
seychelles se comptent sur les doigts
d'une main les doigts d'une main et oui
peut pas parler d'échec par exemple
comme la sénatrice écologiste esther
benbassa qui vit à partir des élèves
sont exclus à cause de l'eau du voile
c'est un échec pas si c'est pas la même
chose c'est que nous avons des
procédures heureusement nous sommes la
france nous essayons et c'est l'idée
même de la laïcité j'ai eu l'occasion de
le rappeler aujourd'hui une gestion
c'est une liberté qui s'adresse à une
autre liberté c'est un rêve ce paix qui
s'adresse à une personne nous essayons
de persuader de convaincre six jeunes
gens ces jeunes filles et leurs familles
et fait confiance aux enseignants ils le
font avec beaucoup de générosité et
d'intelligence républicaine lorsqu'on
n'a plus d'autres moyens parce que ça ne
marche pas parce qu'il ya récidive parce
qu'il ya provocation parce qu'il y avait
trop élitiste alors il ya exclusion pour
un pédagogue c'était déjà le cas vous
savez au début du 20e siècle exclure un
élève c'est toujours un échec et c'est
toujours un crève coeur mais donc
lesquels sont très très bons plans dire
c'est l'honneur de la france cette
affaire-là
et la laïcité elle est partagé par
l'immense majorité des français et car
souvent il ya une laïcité qui l'a
s'adresse essentiellement aux jeunes
gens et jeunes filles issues de l'islam
et qu'il poursuit des musulmans la
majorité la très grande majorité des
musulmans considèrent comme nous tous
que la laïcité est un facteur
d'émancipation peut-être une question
qui est plus ouverte c'est ce qu'il faut
autoriser les parents d'élèves voix les
a accompagnés des sorties scolaires
quelle est votre position oui ou non
c'est moi je suis l'état du droit l'état
du droit aujourd'hui et je n'ai pas
abrogé la circulaire chatel c'est que
les parents accompagnateurs c'était
essentiellement les maires en
l'occurrence sont considérés comme des
auxiliaires du service public s'il ya
des évolutions de notre droit nous
verrons avant donc vous êtes ouvert il
ya une demande qui a été faite par le
défenseur je crois des droits mission
pour l'instant c'est le respect du droit
en république qui les bougies c'est la
loi qui peut vous êtes prêts à
l'accompagner c'est ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui
j'accompagne le droit je pense qu'on
doit avoir la même loi pour tous est un
petit principes républicains qui n'est
pas sot qui peut nous aider compris pour
la laïcité le droit aujourd'hui m'a dit
que ce principe sur lequel le tribunal
administratif de montreuil a statué est
un principe reconnu s'il s'avérait
puisque le défenseur des droits
dominique baudis a saisi le conseil des
états que le conseil d'état dit autre
chose nous tous nous aurons à réfléchir
et vous les auriez ce jour là peut-être
sera votre opinion mon opinion c'est que
là aussi si vous voulez par rapport à
ce qui se passe dans les écoles de
france ça occupe 90 % du débat
médiatique pas un millième des incidents
que j'ai chaque jour que font les
enseignants dans ces cas là mais c'est
toujours pareil e-dialog ils arrivent à
leur fin reconnaît le poids du symbole
dans ces questions a dit moi est ce
qu'il est nécessaire de réunir un
séminaire gouvernemental sur
l'intégration le 9 janvier sachant que
le chef de l'état doit reparler cinq
jours après lors d'une grande conférence
de presse je ne suis pas sûr qu'il ait
été maintenue je crois que ça
va les gars n'ont pas les rapports n'ont
justement pas parce que je voudrais vous
dire une chose il faudrait pas que
l'embryon de polémique à chercher jean
françois copé ne nous amène pas à
considérer vous parliez tout à l'heure
des difficultés du système scolaire
français l' ocde qui n'est pas une
officine gauchistes nous a dit non
seulement que nous sommes le pays le
plus inégalitaire bravo mais
deuxièmement que nous sommes le pays qui
intègre le moins bien les jeunesses
première et deuxième génération bon et
donc moi je soutiens l'idée que nous
devons améliorer notre politique
d'intégration républicaine puisque nous
n'avons pas les résultats que nous
souhaitons je crois d'ailleurs qu'on
peut le faire tout à fait avec notre
laïcité est tout à fait un facteur d'où
la charte de la laïcité douma morale
laïque un facteur d'intégration mais il
ne faudrait pas que l'on oublie ce qui
était l'essentiel de la démarche du
premier ministre ces deux projets sans
tabou la question de l'intégration dacca
alors vous réforme à l'épreuve les
contestations je le disais aussi il ya
un instant vincent peillon vous avez
renoncé à la remise en cause des
horaires et des rémunérations des profs
de classe de prépa ou pourtant vous avez
répété pendant des semaines je ne
reculerai pas vous avez reculé non c'est
pas trop dur non non vous n'avez moi
vous n'avez pas bien suivi mes propos
nous poursuivons les discussions
elle concernait d'ailleurs tous les
métiers du secondaire puisque les
professeurs de classes préparatoires
sont des professeurs du secondaire
j'ai ouvert 13 chantiers sur l'ensemble
des métiers ça peut être les professeurs
du primaire les psychologues scolaires
les directeurs d'école et j'ai dit nous
fermerons les chantiers lorsque nous
aurons trouvé un accord j'ai vu la
question c'est ça va prendre combien de
temps c'est au mois de janvier aussi à
la rentrée 2015 je les avais ouvert le
18 novembre j'en ai déjà fermé 5 le 18
décembre un peu avant même je crois le
et donc nous allons poursuivre la
discussion début janvier plus on ira
vite plus le ministre raconte en bon
est-ce que vous restez sur le principe
est ce qu'on va rester sur le principe
ce qu'ils enseignent aux meilleurs sont
les mieux récompensés les classe de
prépa ou est-ce que ça vous choque
toujours vous pouvez le dire non c'est
pas c'est pas ça qui en fait c'est pour
ça que j'ai voulu qu'on reprenne la
discussion c'est qu'il ya eu comme
souvent entre le ministre et celle à qui
s'adresse plein intermédiaires qui ont
modifié ma pensée et en particulier ce
qui m'avait le plus choqué mais qui
marque bien peu l'état d'esprit du pays
c'était il va prendre à ses professeurs
dont je reconnais le mérite j'estime les
classes préparatoires pour donner à
l'enseignement prioritaire qui méritent
évidemment d'avoir davantage de moyens
j'ai montré que ce n'était pas le cas
puisque ce même jour où j'ai fermé les
chantiers j'ai déjà fait les mesures
pour l'état une partenaire pour les
locations présentation pour dire
regardez ce sont des préjugés ce sont
des on dit ce sont des malveillances à
mon endroit maintenant nous devons
poursuivre la discussion pourquoi parce
que chez les professeurs de classes
préparatoires il y en a qui travaillent
huit 10h20 qui travaillent 16 heures
y'en a qui gagnent 3000 euros par mois
en a qui gagnent de près deux fois et
demi et donc il y as besoin de
transparence d'équité de justice et donc
nous devons avancer
j'ai noté d'ailleurs alors une certaine
satisfaction que les associations de
professeurs de classes préparatoires
souhaité que cette discussion se
poursuive ils ne sont pas du tout
d'accord pour continuer à en parler mais
non ils surent pas du tout alors que
vous avez pré annonce si c'est certain
vous avez raison mais ils sont rémunérés
en pour dire il faut que les choses
changent alors on dit que vous êtes du
coup apple sous surveillance de l'elysée
qu aurait pu jouer un rôle ne pourrait
pas parler de coup d'arrêt m'enfin bon
l'elysée qui juste peut-être qu'elle lie
à ces désordres comme ça avec la
difficile mise en place de la réforme
des rythmes scolaires vincent peillon
cgil est sous surveillance c'est très
injuste c'est un papier du monde que
vous citez qui a été fait malgré les
démentis j'ai rencontré le président de
la république pour lui demander
précisément d'aidé à l'éducation
prioritaire il m'a répondu positivement
et je lui annoncer dans ce rendez vous
ai je vraiment je l'en remercie pour la
france après les résultats pisa dans ce
rendez vous je lui ai annoncé se marrer
ce pont sabilité que j'allais poursuivre
les discussions et
j'ai vu que malgré un rendez-vous à deux
donc un peu de gens qui peuvent parler
j'étais quand même bien placé pour le
faire il faut s'intéresser aux sources
j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises que le
président de la république ne m'avait
pas à demander ne m'avait pas demandé de
revenir en arrière ou de poursuivre la
discussion sur les classes préparatoires
c'est ma décision et maeght dessine la
longueur voilà qui est dit à propos de
la réforme des rythmes scolaires on
attend toujours la réforme qui devrait
normalement aller aller avec ses 7 des
vacances d'été des grandes vacances
alors vous allez les rébus ou pas non on
ne doit pas normalement aller avec gelée
ce que disent certains c'est ce qu'ils
voulaient la semaine et se disent en
réalité puisqu'il 4 sur la semaine
faisons eux cale sur la semaine faisons
l'année donc puisque je peux pas
franchir la première marche je vais
franchir tout l'escalier d'un coup alors
je vous rassure au moment des
concertations très longue qui ont eu
lieu on n'y en a pas eu je leur ai
proposé les mêmes avait dit surtout pas
très bien avec katell prigent de l'
agence france-presse arrive donc pour
évoquer avec vous et bien les
difficultés du gouvernement les
réussites habile y en a aussi maintien
même dans le dialogue social avec michel
sapin mais ce qui frappe l'opinion et
c'est ce qu'indiquent les sondages
d'ailleurs c'est la double face de
françois hollande président de
l'extérieur des idées engagé et le
président de l'intérieur plus louvoyant
jérôme rabier
y aurait-il la tête de l'état un
président à la double personnalité
une sorte de docteur françois et mr
hollande le premier actif sur la scène
internationale ces tranches et engagent
des troupes en quelques heures et assume
ses choix vu l'urgence j'ai décidé
d'agir immédiatement
le second en revanche chargée des
affaires intérieures peine à arrêter une
décision pour preuve les reculs sur
l'écotaxe sur l'épreuve de classe prépa
et évidemment sur la sphère leonarda si
elles ont fait la demande compte tenu
des circonstances
et qu'elle veut poursuivre sa scolarité
en france un accueil lui sera réservé
et elle seule une image qui se
retrouvent dans les enquêtes d'opinion
puisque moins d'un quart des français le
trouve assez autoritaire il ya deux
types de françois hollande aux yeux des
français francs hollande qui leur
satisfait globalement lorsqu'il prend
position au niveau international est en
revanche une interrogations assez fortes
sur la capacité de françois hollande à
pouvoir diriger la france au niveau
intérieur une interrogation sur le cap
qui est fixée une interrogation se
serait capacité à pouvoir prendre la
décision une image ambivalente qui
ressort dans les sondages puisqu'après
sa séquence internationale avec
l'intervention centrafrique et les
obsèques de nelson mandela le chef de
l'état bénéficie d'un rebond de 4 points
dans l' enquête bva du mois de décembre
mais pourquoi n'arrive-t-il pas
appliquer les mêmes recettes sur le plan
de la politique intérieure sans doute
car il est trop préoccupé par les
équilibres d'une majorité qui l'a porté
au pouvoir la gauche au pouvoir est très
divisé et hollande est en permanence
obligé de naviguer entre les différentes
tendances auxquelles ils se heurtent
voyez en ce moment en particulier avec
les verts exigent la proportionnelle
intégrale
ce n'est pas possible de gouverner dans
des conditions pareilles des vertus rue
dans les brancards un front de gauche
incontrôlable et des couacs à répétition
voilà les ingrédients qui complique la
tâche du président même si dans son camp
on préfère miser sur le long terme
réussir dans la durée et pas seulement
sur un grand soir avec ce c'est éternel
remords d'être au pouvoir que la gauche
porte comme un fardeau et dont nous
sommes en train de nous des pets parce
qu'on a envie justement de nous inscrire
dans cette durée une volonté qui se
heurte à l'impératif de résultat que
réclament les français car in fine et
c'est sur sa capacité à trancher qu'il
sera jugé voilà qu'à tel président de l'
agence france-presse
vos questions à vincent peillon alors
est-ce qu'il ya 2 françois hollande
celui qui s'est très bien tranchée à
l'étranger et celui qui hésitent
davantage quand il s'agit de politique
intérieure je suis très étonné de et
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire que
l'on puisse séparer les deux je vous
prendre des exemples un président de la
république de gauche qui dit je vais
baisser le coût du travail
c'est une innovation radicale 20
milliards d'euros pour les entreprises
et j'entends il serait l'otage des
majorités de gauche c'était quand même
pas traditionnel à gauche de se dire le
premier problème de compétitivité une
mesure d'un courage considérable elle
est passée sous entendre une deuxième on
est assistée ça n'est pas fini ils
manifestent encore ce soir
devant une réunion madame taubira le
mariage pour tous bah il a manqué de
courage il m'a pas semblé il ya eu de
grandes manifestations
le président a continué la priorité à
l'école la possibilité de réformer les
retraites le marché du travail donc en
un an et demi sur l'ensemble des sujets
le président a montré en france comme à
l'étranger qu'il était non seulement un
homme qui décide qui est capable d'être
courageux et il faut bien le dire de
rencontrer une certaine adversité
parfois et je vous rassure c'est comme
pour chacun d'entre vous c'est le même
homme est d'ailleurs j'attire
l'attention des français regardez bien
vous vous dites sur le plan étrangers et
c'est aussi la façon qu'on a souvent en
france de ne pas s'aimer nous-mêmes ce
plan étrangers a c'est vrai il prend des
décisions à sauver l'euro il se bat pour
la directive détachement il obtient
l'union bancaire il va au mali où il
fait pareil en france et même la
priorité à l'école que je porte dans un
pays qui a si peu de facilité à
s'occuper de ses enfants depuis
longtemps on a vu avec les résultats
c'est courageux parce que c'est pas si
populaire pendant les moyens peut être
pas les capacités mentales et moyens
s'occuper de ses enfants non la france
et on vient de le voir dans pisa depuis
2003 en 2012 on est le pays le plus
inégalitaire et celui qui décline ça n'a
pas provoqué de grandes manifestations
on a supprimé 80 mille postes supprimés
les raisons d'être en difficulté
supprimer la formation des professeurs
et on voit bien qu'on préférait faire
des gesticulations sur identité
nationale et immigration aborder les
vrais problèmes apporter des réponses
c'est devenu courageux et donc c'est le
même homme comme à l'étranger à l'inter
il ya quand même quelques couacs au sein
du gouvernement
depuis depuis un an on voit on l'a vu
aussi les divisions avec les verts et
puis on a l'impression si en ce moment
avec le premier ministre quelle est
l'ambiance parce que il ya eu le
recadrage sur la remise à plat du
système fiscal
il ya eu là ici aussi cette idée on
vient d'en discussions soient
intéressants
au moment du chef de l'état parle
d'énervement du chef de l'état notamment
visuel son premier mini je vais être
désobligeant à l'égard de personnes mais
je ne sais pas qui on jeudi à longueur
de journée les papiers qu'ils ne sont
pas sûrs si vous l'avez très aimablement
rappeler je suis numéro trois du
gouvernement il se fait que je vois de
temps en temps le président de la
république et le premier ministre il se
fait que je peux parler avec eux de ces
réformes de très grande importance la
fiscalité n'a fait déjà d'ailleurs
beaucoup de réformes on peut en parler
ou les questions on vient d'évoquer je
vous en remercie d'intégration alors moi
je vous dis les choses avec beaucoup de
netteté et d'ailleurs heureusement il
n'y a aucun désaccord entre le président
de la république et le premier ministre
depuis des mois et des mois parce qu'il
faut alimenter la chronique et puis
peut-être certains ont des ambitions on
va changer de gouvernement il ya des
difficultés il n'y en n'a pas nous avons
pris un pays dans une crise épouvantable
où le savez tous on était en récession à
croissance 0 6 1 milliards de dettes en
plus un chômage qui ne cessé de
progresser fait quand même six mois que
le chômage des jeunes baisse et donc
faut travailler alors on est dans un
monde qui est ce qu'il est et où il ya
beaucoup de commentaires où il ya
beaucoup de doute beaucoup de
scepticisme parfois un peu de violence
mais il faut travailler sérieusement
et je me réchauffe et son de cloche
différent mais on en attend 10 de remise
à plat on sent quand même que françois
hollande tomas jurco temporise revient
limite revient un peu en arrière là
dessus non c'est la façon peut-être
d'expliciter ce que nous voulons dire
qu'ils donnent le sentiment une nuance
un joueur mais j'étais sauf que j'ai
raison c'est une interview des échos
vous le savez qui a été l'interview du
premier ministre qui est paru un mardi
le lundi soir j'étais avec lui et à et
bien entendu comme vous le savez à
jérusalem en direct au téléphone il y
avait le président de la république qui
travaillait avec le premier ministre
donc il faut cesser en permanence de
regarder des détails mal source et on ne
sait pas qui parle il faut regarder les
réformes alors donc jamais serait-il
toujours premier ministre en 2014 mais
il ya aucune raison de changer le
gouvernement là vous avez un
gouvernement qui commence à avoir des
résultats sur le plan du chômage vous
avez des éléments de retour de
croissance nous sommes en train de
regarder le travail accompli par michel
sapin remarquable cette semaine ça fait
20 ans moi j'ai connu livre blanc sur la
formation professionnelle qu'on
attendait que les chômeurs ceux qui ont
le moins de qualification puissent
bénéficier des fonds de la formation et
on a même au passage vous l'avez vu ça
aurait pu intéresser la droite réussi à
changer le financement des organisations
par la formation professionnelle tout ça
par la concertation donc je ne vois pas
pourquoi ce gouvernement dans tous les
ordres j'ai vu aussi le travail fait par
benoît hamon c'est bien dix jours est au
travail coin après les municipales oui
j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour mme écoles
avec ça peut arriver et je trouve que ce
gouvernement travaille bien je le fais
tranquillement il travaille bien mais
vous disiez tout à l'heure certains
peut-être des ambitions l'ambition de
devenir numéro un du gouvernement
pourquoi pas après les municipales
chrono aujourd'hui quand on est numéro 3
pourquoi pas aussi ce n était pas du
tout à ça que je songeais pour un oui
j'ai la naïveté encore incroyable sur le
commentaire sans doute d'un certain
nombre de collègues légitimement et là
un moment qui en remanient mans avec un
espoir de rentrer gouvernement c'est la
vie politique ce gouvernement on est
dans une période très particulière il
faut mesurer la crise que nous
traversions c'était d'ailleurs le nak
motifs de ce qui était notre campagne
dégager un peu l'avenir le redressement
du pays donc oui on n'est pas
nécessairement populaire ça demande des
efforts il faut sans doute aussi parfois
ajuster nos politiques parce que
l'environnement change mais nous sommes
et chacun a sa tâche
on parler d'ambitions numéro 3 vous êtes
dans un numéro 3 ce ministère qui était
annoncée un peu comme un boulevard une
priorité l'enseignement on l'a vu quand
même sa grippe un peu est ce que comme
vous l'avez dit ou écrit vous êtes sur
un toboggan d'abord je ne les suis libre
dans l'expression exploit là donc un
tweet que qu'on la mène donc vous savez
c'est toujours pareil il faut commenter
des propos qui sont écoutés quelle
chance d'abord numéro 3 vous m'a demandé
mes ambitions depuis combien de temps la
france dans la difficulté où elle est
sur le plan scolaire que vous avez
rappelé attendez que ce soit une
priorité dans le fond c'est pas moi
numéro trois c'est l'école c'est l'école
qui a une priorité l'homme compte peu en
18 mois tout le monde en convient vous
avez dit sa grippe mais en réalité même
la droite vient est dit mais on savait
qu'il fallait faire la priorité aux
primaires il fallait assurer les
remplacements
il faut former les enseignants il faut
passer au numérique c'est tout ce que
nous sommes en train de faire il faut
revoir les programmes et les uns et les
autres savent bien que j'ai cette
passion pour l'école nous travaillons
beaucoup depuis 18 mois nous avons
effectivement le soutien du président et
du premier ministre c'est plus facile
pour un ministre de l'éducation
nationale on a vu les résultats de la
france on ne peut pas s'arrêter donc ça
n'est pas nécessairement du fait divers
de l'émotion ces réformes sont parfois
compliqué à expliquer elles peuvent
trouver des résistances regarder les
rythmes alors que tout le monde était
peau mais il faut le faire et donc nous
avancions j'ai commencé l'avancé le
premier jour et je continuerai sur vos
ambitions personnelles là vous pouvez
pas nier vous serez sur les européennes
région sud est vous allez pouvoir mener
de front et c'est l'ambition de ce grand
ministère comme vous le dites depuis le
premier jour et une campagne européenne
je vous le promets si vous me le
demandez souvent je l'entends d'ailleurs
y compris l'assemblée nationale les gens
s'inquiètent j'ai annoncé la réforme des
statuts de tous les enseignants nous
avons annoncé des mesures pour le
collège nous sommes entre elle et je
vais aujourd'hui annoncé la réforme de
l'éducation prioritaire et je l'entends
et 10 arrêtez arrêtez il fait des
réformes tout le temps eh bien je vais
continuer les réformes ma capacité de
travail n'est pas et mouche et je
connais bien le ministère de l'éducation
nationale et en même temps je ferai
cette campagne parce qu'elle est
fondamental d'abord c'est ce que je dois
aux français les hommes politiques vous
savez heureusement ils passent par le
suffrage universel moi c'est mon mandat
je n'ai pas d'autres c'est d'ailleurs
est toujours mandat unique on n'est pas
occupé votre siège à strasbourg alors
les gens se disent là c'est pas possible
on vois pas quelqu'un qui va pas occuper
mais c'est déjà de sortie pour après ou
mais ça me permet de vous préciser une
chose très simple quand les députés
ministres vont aux législatives lorsque
ils sont élucidées le cas de
l'intégralité du gouvernement ils savent
qu'ils ne vont pas siéger au palais
bourbon le soir où sur les us et leurs
suppléants mais jean menait la campagne
si tous les chefs de file ne l'a mené
pas surtout quand c'est leur siège moi
c'est mon siège par siège que je vais
occuper pour la première fois on ne
comprendrait pas si d'ailleurs je
n'allais pas aux élections au suffrage
universel je serai après au gouvernement
numéro 3 vous l'avez rappelé vous-même
au titre de la société civile ce serait
une curiosité certains s'y sont essayés
c'est pas toujours facile pour gagner
ces arbitrages politiques donc voilà
nous sommes dans des choses qui sont de
l'ordre du commentaire mais si on va sur
le fond le plus important pour moi c'est
que l'on comprenne deux choses ces
élections européennes elles sont
fondamentales
70% de la loi française vient de
l'europe la france repliée sur elle-même
c'est une france qui meurent comme tout
organisme nous avons besoin de l'europe
ait besoin de la réorienter et donc il
faut s'engager et que le gouvernement
s'engage dans le débat européen
deuxièmement les uns et les autres nous
annonce que pour la première fois ce
serait pas que français se seraient
européens le fonds national serait le
premier parti de france et moi qui étais
contre jean marie le pen la dernière
fois moi qui porte ces valeurs
républicaines je dirais à bascous si
justement je suis confortable non je ne
vais pas mener là c'est parce que c'est
parce qu'elles ont trouvé jean michel
avait reporté notamment combat ça vous a
motivé c'est parce que les idées c'est
parce que je ne vais pas lâcher ceux
avec qui j'ai fait et pour l'europe et
pour le combat républicain et les deux
se rejoignent à ce moment là je dois
mener ce combat un combat quand même
difficile je crois bien là dessus en
étant ministre on s'éloigne un petit peu
quand même de la règle tacite qui disait
que les ministres seraient entièrement
consacrés à leur chat que certains se
réjouissent dans votre travail va
peut-être se calmer un peu dans sa
volonté réformatrice
parent maintenant peut-être d'assises il
va un peu moins réformer pendant un mois
et demi et ben je vais les décevoir nous
avons beaucoup de choses à faire nous
les ferons et je ferai la campagne dans
le respect des règles républicaines en
séparant bien les deux activités mais je
le ferai j'ai réfléchi depuis très
longtemps vous savez j'étais encore à
alger hier où j'ai travaillé en
coopération avec les algériennes j'ai
été celui qui a porté au parlement
européen le leonardo vers la
méditerranée j'ai été le rapporteur de
l'union pour la méditerranée je connais
tous ces sujets je veux une france et
une europe ouverte et je veux qu'on soit
capable parce qu'on va voir un combat
extraordinaire pour la première fois et
là les français n'ont pas encore saisi
c'est que cette fois ci lorsqu'on va
voter pour le parlement européen on va
voter en même temps pour le président de
la commission donc le vote va avoir
beaucoup plus d'un pas lent et je veux
qu'il n'y ait pas cette abstention qu'on
a connu de scrutin en scrutin dans cette
élection européenne il faut s'engager
faut mener campagne faut être présent
alors il ya un point important ce mardi
c'est bien à l'entrée en fonction d'un
gala merkel à elle est lancée là sur son
3ème mandat on prête à l'allemagne
peut-être la volonté de plus avancée
vers l'europe fédéraliste vincent
peillon peut être votre ambition
également d'abord j'aimerais savoir quel
est votre sentiment quand vous voyez
cette grosse coalition comme on dit en
allemagne à la droite la gauche les
conservateurs les sociaux démocrates
réunis et vous appuyez un peu à l'unité
tout nationale d'une certaine manière
tout à l'heure sur les questions
d'éducation sur 700 m celui de
l'éducation nationale passait là par
exemple ce serait un modèle pour la
france cette grosse coalition chacun a
son histoire mais belle leçon de
démocratie belle leçon de démocratie
parce que vous avez une chancelière très
forte mais qui finalement n'a pas la
majorité vous avez un spd relativement
affaibli et vous avez des gens qui
commencent je pense que vous avez vu le
traité d'accord c'est 180 ans 180 pas
l'excès montrer si belle couverture
bleue et hier les hôtes absolument
extrêmement précis c'est à dire que tout
est mis sur la table parfois dans le
détail ça pourrait nous inspirer étonné
et hier harlem désir nous avait conviés
à une réflexion avec martin schulz qui
vous le savez un des grands dirigeants
le spd le président du parlement
européen et sera notre candidat des
sociaux démocrates à la présidence de la
commission et il nous rappelait que les
460 mille militants du spd ont voté à 80
% en travaillant les uns et les autres
sur la précision de ce rapport et donc
je trouve que c'est une belle leçon de
démocratie et deuxièmement tu es un
exemple à suivre demain en tout cas il
ya déjà des progrès qui sont importants
puisque vous l'avez vu sur le salaire
par exemple mais je relève un minimum
j'ai plus complet j'ai bien compris
alors vous répondez pas aux samoa leur
revient je pense en tout cas qu'il ya un
certain nombre de sujets six agrès et me
dire où il serait utile on a évoqué la
laïcité tout à l'heure on a parlé de
l'école ou si la france veut être
capable de régler ces problèmes il faut
qu'elles ne tombent pas toujours dans
des petits jeux politiciens avec les
paralyse les uns et les autres merci
quand elle allait perrine tarneaud de
public sénat arrive maintenant vincent
peillon elle va vous interroger sur
d'autres sujets on va évoquer notamment
mais bien parler jean françois copé on a
bien compris ce que vous en pensez à moi
on va vous interrogé notamment sur le
retour annoncé de nicolas sarkozy plus
de doute apparemment même si sa prise de
parole officielle se fera encore
attendre quelques mois sophie normand
couturier
françois hollande et nicolas sarkozy
côte à côte dans les tribunes du stade
de soweto pour l'hommage à nelson
mandela c'était mardi dernier une trêve
avant la reprise des hostilités dans la
perspective de 2017 car le retour en
politique de nicolas sarkozy s'accélère
l'ancien chef de l'état pourrait revenir
dès 2014 même si officiellement le
moment n'est pas venu je pense que ne
refera plus jamais de politique
aussant ce quotidien au sens partisan en
revanche si la situation exige son
retour est bien dans ces cas là sans
doute le devoir l'appellera nicolas
sarkozy l'homme providentiel sauveur
d'une france à la déroute dans ses
bureaux de la rue de miromesnil c'est un
flux discontinue l'ancien président
reçoit écoute des visiteurs de tous les
bords et de tous les secteurs il en
ressort des confidences distillées dans
la presse dernière en date relatée par
l'hebdomadaire le point nicolas sarkozy
aurait déclaré la question n'est pas de
savoir si je veut ou ne veut pas revenir
je ne peux pas ne pas revenir je n'ai
pas le choix c'est une fatalité une
seule interrogation alors quand
reviendra-t-il le plus tard sera le
mieux sans être dans la fable de la
fontaine il faut bien faire attention
lièvre donc il faut arriver au moment où
c'est vraiment indispensable recommanda
avril une connerie par jour qui est fait
et autres invités en sait quelque chose
aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il pourra revenir au jeu
penseurs 2015 nicolas sarkozy face à
françois hollande en 2017 un petit goût
de déjà vu mais c'est sans compter
marine le pen qui pourrait venir
troubler le jeu s'il a envie de revenir
qui reviennent mais on l'attend à moi
j'attends avec impatience le retour de
nicolas sarkozy alors lequel d'ailleurs
le nicolas sarkozy bissonnet sq ou le
nicolas sarkozy kouchner ise on sait
jamais trop avec lui s'il revenait
nicolas sarkozy pourrait en effet
rassembler au delà de l'ump son
entourage pense aux centristes mais
l'ouverture pourrait aussi se faire à
gauche
sarkozy leur tour une fatalité dit
l'ancien président
quel point de vue du philosophe sur son
fatalité et un destin comme ça en
politique auquel on ne peut pas échapper
vous savez un très bon mot de
arthur rimbaud dans une saison en enfer
où il finit en disant ma faim c'est rare
une fatalité de bonheur bon a priori
quand on entend fatalité on s'est dit
c'est un lapsus parce que fatalité c'est
quand même plutôt négatifs ont droit et
je vais j'essaie d'être positif et je
vais même chercher chez rimbaud mais
alors ce sera quoi nourrir sont mesquins
une fatalité de quoi si c'était
effectivement confirmé ce retour chez
moi je ne suis pas dans la position vous
devez le comprendre mais les
commentateurs mais oui je suis ce que
j'observe comme vous c'est que depuis 18
mois et quoi qu'en dise la michard ont
peut-être la gauche éprouvent des
difficultés en tout cas en terme
d'opinion elle agit pour le reste est à
l'essai de servir le pays mais à droite
ça va très mal et d'ailleurs vous êtes
devant deux choses ces divisions qui ne
sont pas réglés on a eu le feuilleton
copé fillon qui a été terrible on a
maintenant en suspension le retour de
sarkozy on a aussi l'icône alain juppé
et on a une jeune génération qui
piaffent d'impatience pour venir en 2010
est donc à une crise du leadership
derrière la crise du leadership il ya
plus grave il ya une crise du projet car
on peut parler tous les ténors de l'ump
sont réunis à une convention de l'ump
pour proposer le pour présenter le
programme économique et social de l'ump
donc des mesures jour leur unité avec
des mesures d'urgence l'année qui
commence je vais vous dire si c'est le
cas si l'ump un projet pour la france
qui soit pas on va supprimer 1 million
de fonctionnaires on va des choses
qu'ils ne feront pas d'un projet sérieux
pour le moment de l'alternance sommes un
pays connu l'alternance nous sommes
capables de nous respecter ce serait une
bonne nouvelle dit concernant ces
réformes pour l'éducation nationale nous
notre vin des mais comme ce sont tous
les rapports de la cour des comptes
sur le thème en dépense beaucoup on a
peu de résultats non mais c'est tout à
fait inexact puisque la cour des comptes
recommande un certain nombre de choses
et en réalité c'est la politique que je
mène qui correspond le plus que ce soit
la réforme de l'éducation prioritaire la
remise en place de la formation des
enseignants est donc sur tous ces sujets
sous la réserve de la question du statut
des enseignants mais je suis le premier
dans ce pays attaqué sérieusement et en
tout cas à m dans le débat et nous avons
déjà avancé tout cela ça n'est pas
sérieux mais moi je suis je suis pour
que la droite soit sérieuse je suis
malheureux quand je vois le rpr courir
invoquée par nicolas sarkozy mais aussi
la réalité des sondages quand on voit le
dernier sondage paru dans le figaro
magazine ce week-end 47% des français
qui préférerait avoir nicolas sarkozy
aujourd'hui à l'elysée contre 27% à
françois hollande à écouter en tout cas
ce que j'ai noté et qu'on risque de voir
rapidement c'est que même si les
français nous reproche un certain nombre
de choses et c'est l'évidence ils n'ont
pas un appétit de la droite puisqu'il
pense que la droite ne ferait pas mieux
si la droite peut se préparer à faire
mieux tant mieux pour la france c'est
pas le cas pour l'instant et je trouve
qu'au contraire le spectacle qu'ils ont
donnée depuis 18 mois on la donnait
autrefois mais nous sommes vraiment loin
du compte et donc il ya ce que cette
crise de leadership a pas finit pas moi
qui vais apporter un jugement sur le
retour ou pas nicolas sarkozy je n'aurai
pas à voter dans une primaire pour
nicolas sarkozy c'est entre eux on peut
depuis sa mort à autrui primaire et
peut-être pas mais en tout cas c'est un
problème qui appartient la droite
républicaine et puis deuxièmement est un
sujet plus important c'est qu'elles sont
leurs propositions pour la france ce
qu'ils ont gouverné ils ont gouverné 10
ans et alors on peut prendre sujet par
sujet ça n'a pas été brillant du tout
sûr à la fois les questions économiques
les questions sociales les questions
éducatives connaître et de leur
programme au mois de janvier vincent une
question d'actualité avec logo et michel
gaudin l'ancien préfet de police sont en
garde à vue depuis ce matin dans la
sphère des primes en liquide versé au
ministère de l'intérieur entre 2002 et
2004 selon vous c'est le système sarkozy
qui est en accusation ce soir j'ai comme
règle de ne pas commenter
les affaires de justice il ya une
affaire qui est en cours et qu'elle se
poursuive en parler du front national
tout à l'heure jean françois copé accuse
le parti socialiste de faire monter le
fn car selon lui le ps essaie de
favoriser les triangulaires du coup le
ps pourra conserver plus de ville qu'est
ce que vous lui répondez je lui réponds
vraiment avec parce que je ne veux pas
qu'on pense qu'il ya quelque chose de
personnel c'est pas du tout le cas c'est
une question de responsabilité politique
je considère qu'elle que chef d'un grand
parti comme l'ump
ça impose un certain nombre de
responsabilités dans le débat public le
jeu de c'est toi qui fait monter le
front national c'est le jeu d'installer
le front national au coeur de la
campagne ce n'est pas une bonne idée que
chacun fasse ses propositions la gauche
les siennes la droite les siennes et
cherche ne cherche pas ni sur les thèmes
ni sur dans ce genre de vocabulaire à
instrumentaliser et je rajoute que
lorsque nous avons dû prendre nos
responsabilités je l'évoqué sur 2002
tout à l'heure je les ai rappelés sur le
var nous les prenons c'est à dire que
nous nous faisons la différence entre un
candidat ump et un candidat du front
national il faut qu'ils aient la même
clarté partout il faut que chacun fasse
ses propositions et avance je note et je
le redis que je le souhaite aussi pour
l'unité et la capacité à avoir un débat
public de qualité de l'air à l'intérieur
de l'ump ça fait quand même maintenant
un an que les positions monsieur copé
pose des problèmes il ya d'autres
positions vous avez peut-être pu lire
hier dans le monde la tribune d'henri
guaino pour lui le front national n'est
plus un parti d'extrême droite est-ce
que marine le pen a donc réussi son
entreprise de dédiabolisation pardon du
front national c'est un papier qui était
très intéressant qu'il est plus complexe
puisque il parle à la fois il dit sous
peine de provocation d'un adn dont on a
bien compris qu'il est quand tu es quand
même des crèmes droite même d'origine
fasciste il explique que c'est un parti
inhumain c'est à dire ceux qui dénigrent
et l'appartenance à une même humanité
jeudi à meaux lisez le fn s'est pas pour
autant la banque centrale a donc vous
aurez remarqué que même certainement
mais non mais même papier il y avait
quand même certains éléments
contradictoires cela étant c'est un
papier de bonne qualité
les jeunes du front national détournent
aujourd'hui une affiche de françois
mitterrand la force tranquille en france
tranquille on va semble pouvoir voir la
fiche sur les écrans derrière vous
quelle est votre réaction
ma réaction fondamentale on parlait de
l'europe tout à l'heure qui pensent
qu'on va améliorer la situation de la
france en sortant de l'euro personnes et
si cela arrivait pas une folie mais qui
est arrivé dans l'histoire des votes
extrémistes les grandes dérives alors
c'est les français les premiers et les
français les plus modestes qui
supporterait les conséquences de cette
politique et donc je considère que
madame le pen qui continue d'ailleurs de
diviser les français avec des principes
qui ne sont pas conformes ainsi peu
républicain de stigmatisation des uns et
des autres d'opposition les uns et des
autres et bien que madame le pen ne rend
pas service à la france et n'aiment pas
la france que j'aime c'est à dire la
france républicaine est le vrai fn qui
s'inspire de plus en plus du programme
économique de la gauche populiste est ce
que ce sont les extrêmes qui se
rejoignent je crois que c'est de la
démagogie c'est à dire qu'on a un front
national qui je suis madame le pen qui
va chercher à être attrape-tout et donc
qui va prendre tout ce qui dans son idée
pourra séduire les uns et les autres
mais je le dis à tous elle vous a déjà
trahi son adn n'a pas changé elle vous
trahira demain et cette manoeuvre est
une manoeuvre purement politique en même
temps pour la france si on aime on va
être gardé à l'extérieur il faut
véritablement que les citoyens français
mesurent que ce n'est pas une
plaisanterie on peut pas être
indifférent il faut se mobiliser et vous
savez c'est essentiellement évidemment
aux européennes que cette question va se
jouer or quel est l'ennemi est ce qui
permet au front national de faire des
voix aux européennes c'est l'abstention
parce que les gens se disent c'est
décourageant peut rien y faire on ne
comprend pas et c'est bien là vous avez
un motif c'est le front républicain la
possibilité je lui ai dit de choisir
président de la commission dont veut
changer la politique européenne mais
derrière il ya un vrai motif c'est de
s'opposer à ces idées de haine entre
française qu'il faut permettre au fonds
national de rentrer par exemple à
l'assemblée nationale en introduisant
plus de proportionnelle aux élections
législatives c'est aux partenaires les
verts europe ecologie les verts qui le
réclament et c'est dedans un engagement
de campagne de françois hollande non oui
d'abord vous avez raison mais la
position qui a été celle du président du
groupe écologique au sénat jean vincent
placé aujourd'hui était celle d'une
proportionnelle intégrale n'a jamais été
notre position s'il ya possibilité d'un
stylet dose de proportionnelle elle
était de 10% vous venez y avait des
textes plus anciens mais 10% moi je
considère que l'on peut en débattre très
bien on peur de l'autre
je n'ai pas d'opposition personnellement
de principe chez très anciens c'était
d'ailleurs le cas du président du groupe
où le savez
socialiste au sénat nous étions exprimés
ya quelques années moi je n'ai pas
changé de position je considérais pour
qu'il y est je ne suis pas son
porte-parole mais je considère pour
qu'il y ait un débat apaisé juste un
engagement que nous avions pris que
toutes les familles puissent être
représentées donc cette dose de
proportionnelle qui est comme mineur ne
met pas en question la stabilité des
institutions le fait majoritaire est
tout à fait fondamental n'est pas en
dessous d'un pronom au cours de cette
émission en tant que numéro trois du
gouvernement va simplement vous avez
défendu un peu tous vos camarades vous
l'avez souligné vous même
si les réformes dans tous les secteurs
et résistera encore des amabilités sur
les secondes alors se dit finalement
alors que l'ambition c'est pas matignon
un jour mais peut-être patron du ps non
c'est vrai on vous a trouvé aussi très
combatif j'avais j'ai été dix on la
savait mieux que personne dans
l'opposition
génération politique qui a connu le 21
avril 2002 la politique n'était pas mon
premier choix je me suis engagé assez
tard j'aimerais qu'on réussisse
j'aimerais que la gauche réussisse
j'aimerais qu'on fasse réussir notre
pays c'est déjà du parti socialiste met
à la place où je suis j'ai déjà assez à
faire et quand vous dites vous dites du
bien d un développement je veux que nous
réussissons notre action et je crois que
l'essentiel pour nous c'est d'être à
cette tâche jean michel baylet qui
disait ce matin le patron des radicaux
de gauche qui avait pas assez d'élan
parti socialiste vous partager sa
position je ne partage aucune position
qui consiste à critiquer ses camarades
or facile alors
quand même vous avez été douché quand
même par les revirements successifs des
syndicats vous l'avez rappelé sur la
semaine de quatre jours et demi ce que
vous avez un l'impression là où vous
êtes d'être d'affronter une ligne
maginot 1
le conservatisme absolu non je n'en je
trouve que il ya quelque chose en france
qui est très frappant c'est que la faute
c'est toujours les autres quand vous
regardez la sphère des rythmes syndicats
ne sont pas contents c'est surtout
d'ailleurs souvent ceux qui étaient sur
le terrain qui sont pas contents qu'elle
ministre demande de venir travailler une
demi journée de plus le mercredi matin
salut à vous parliez tout à l'heure du
courage il en fallait un certain soutenu
par le président de la république les
parents ont pas l'air ça change des
habitudes du mardi soir très content et
collectivités locales se dit c'est dur
pourquoi tout d'un coup une seule qu'on
adore
parce que je n'ai pas dormi de médecine
vient de republier ces travaux s'est
discutée par personne y compris pas par
ceux qui le contestent aujourd'hui qu'on
changer la vie en 24 heures mais c'est
pour vous dire que moi je conçois que
cette réforme difficile pour tout le
monde mais je ne vois pas pourquoi on
dirait c'est seulement les syndicats
c'est pour tout le monde qu'elle est
difficile et donc c'est tout d'abord le
ministre aussi le ministre et c'est avec
beaucoup de conviction art et passion
parce que je sais j'ai la certitude que
c'est l'intérêt des élèves à voir du
meilleur temps scolaire le mercredi
matin ça permettra à lutter contre ces
inégalités et cette baisse du niveau et
avoir du meilleur temps périscolaire ce
sera aussi très vite merci vincent
peillon merci perrine allez on se
retrouve début janvier maintenant très
bonnes fêtes vous tous on se retrouve
très vite et notre premier invité en
janvier sera gérard larcher en foire